also eine große diskussion durch die
politik durch die bundespolitik und die
landespolitik wir warten darauf dass
sich bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
vielleicht dazu äußert das wurde uns
zumindest angekündigt sie ist gerade auf
einer veranstaltung der
konrad-adenauer-stiftung hier sehen wir
den livestream und wir hören mal rein
haupt dort schon etwas zu der aktuellen
thematik gesagt wird 80 hingewiesen und
was wir heute in diesen tagen ganz
besonders ist dass jede generation
wieder ihre aufgaben zu lösen hat europa
ist nicht so dass man sagen kann dass
besteht und das funktioniert sondern
europa hat heute ganz andere probleme
als damals aber die sind auch ganz
massiv und in diesen tagen bewegt uns
neben der gesundheit von herrn dabei nie
zum beispiel die frage des
flüchtlingslagers in moria und dort
bündelt sich im grunde wie in einem
brennglas die ganze problematik der
migration mit der wir uns seit 2005 10
beschäftigen
und wir wissen im grunde seit langem
dass menschen dort unter unwürdigen
bedingungen leben und nicht nur dort
aber eben dort auch und der brand hat
uns noch mal so zu sagen wie im
brennglas gezeigt was das problem ist
und jetzt geht es vor allen dingen darum
das habe ich mit dem griechischen
ministerpräsidenten diskutiert dass wir
erst einmal sofort helfen neue und
bessere unterbringung für die menschen
dort sicher zu stellen so kann es nicht
bleiben und deutschland wird sich daran
beteiligt und gleichzeitig habe ich den
griechischen ministerpräsidenten gefragt
was können wir helfen und seine bitte
war dass wir insbesondere die
minderjährigen die jetzt ja auch auf das
griechische festland gebracht wurden
aufnehmen wir haben mit frankreich
kontakt aufgenommen
deutschland und frankreich werden sich
daran beteiligen ich hoffe einige andere
mitgliedstaaten auch denn
die migration das ist weder das problem
der länder bei den menschen ankommen
alleine ist es auch nicht alleine ein
deutsches problem wir haben die
ratspräsidentschaft
und deshalb muss es noch mehr eine
europäische verantwortung werden und ich
bin sehr dankbar dass die kommission
jetzt noch einmal einen anlauf machen
wird am 30 september vorschläge vorlegen
wird und deutschland wird kämpfen der
bundesinnenminister und ich und alle die
ganze bundesregierung dass wir endlich
zu mehr gemeinsamer verantwortung kommen
denn wir haben eben nicht nur moorea
deutschland nimmt jeden tag 300
flüchtlinge etwa auf wir haben ganz
schlimme situation in bosnien
herzegowina in vielen staaten des
westlichen balkans wo wir auch
unterstützen und wir können dieses
problem nur gemeinsam lösen also in
einem ersten schritt jetzt das angebot
an griechenland für die minderjährigen
flüchtlinge und es müssten weitere
schritte folgen für gemeinsame
verantwortung deutschland hat sich
dieser verantwortung gestellt aber wir
können nicht zufrieden sein mit einer
europäischen migrationspolitik die gibt
es im grunde heute so nicht und wenn das
so bleibt ist das eine schwere bürde für
europa und deshalb werden wir unsere
ratspräsidentschaft nutzen um hier
fortschritte zu machen
sie haben da gerade einen sehr wichtigen
punkt angesprochen mit denen ihr auch
gern mit mit denen ich auch gerne über
sie sprechen möchte hätte man zwar würde
mich interessieren die bahn von 2014 bis
2019 eu-ratspräsident wie groß denken
wir die chance dass bei der europäischen
asylpolitik jetzt doch noch eine
gemeinsame lösung gefunden werden kann
und da würde sich dann auch noch die
frage an schließen welche möglichkeiten
wie das man dann vielleicht auch noch
europäische staaten aus zentral- und
osteuropäischen ländern auf die ich mich
beziehe mit an den tisch holen und da
vielleicht auf einen gemeinsamen nenner
kommt sofort in mariazell
[Musik]
politik kannst du
controlling aber es sei aber dass das
mehr titel
die menschen sind in julia saner
verändert dass das topic
unfortunately wärme effektiv politiker
tun egal denn die interne politik
[Musik]
motto du heute trat auf das discovery
box und das ist etwas drin
soweit also die worte von donald tusk
dem präsidenten der europäischen
volkspartei und bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel zu der problematik die sich jetzt
ergeben hat durch den brand im lager
moria auf der insel lesbos in
griechenland zu gehört unser
korrespondent theo koll in
hauptstadtstudio berlin der ist uns
weiterhin zugeschaltet ich fast noch mal
ganz kurz zusammen ich habe ein bisschen
mit geschrieben also frau merkel hat
gesagt in moria bündelt sich das problem
der migration wissen seit langem dass
menschen dort unter unwürdigen
bedingungen leben der brand hat gezeigt
was das problem ist jetzt hat sie mit
dem griechischen ministerpräsidenten
gesprochen der hat auch ungebeten pool
minderjährige flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
deutschland und frankreich werden sich
beteiligen aber sie und auch herthas
gerade haben noch mal dringend darauf
hingewiesen dass ein europäisches
problem
und dann gab es die sehr deutlichen
worte wir können nicht zufrieden sein
mit der europäischen migrationspolitik
die gibt es im grunde nichts
das ist doch schon ein ganz klarer
rüffel theo koll aus berlin in richtung
brüssel und in die restlichen
nachbarstaaten die sich verweigern oder
in der tat das waren sehr deutliche
worte es gibt keine europäische
migrationspolitik und das sei eine sehr
schwere bürde sagt sie also sie ist
sogar schon mal so gesagt nicht dass ich
wüsste sie ist ja nicht nur kanzlerin
sondern im moment auch amtierende
eu-präsident in insofern ist das schon
eine sehr klare ansage
wobei interessanterweise wenn man das in
der kombination nimmt mit dem polnischen
gast donald tusk und das ist insofern
eine glückliche fügung dass die beiden
jetzt auf diesem podium zu einem ganz
anderen thema sind denn donald tusk hat
natürlich auch den blick der polin die
ja beispielsweise mit den ungarn zu den
größten kritikern einer
migrationspolitik in europa zählen und
tusk hat sehr gewandt er hat gesagt wir
haben eine das problem der migration
nicht gelöst er hat noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen
dass sich politisch seit der migrations
krise 2015 nichts verändert die
positionen haben sich nicht verändert
und der mahnte zur vorsicht er sagte
moura wird die einstellung in europa
nicht verändern also das fand ich einen
sehr interessanten kritischen blick und
genau das ist das problem dass europa
keine die europäische union hat keine
einheit keine einheitliche haltung zu
diesem problem aus vielen gründen
also wir sehen ja auch in der in der
bundesrepublik dass die risse dadurch
die lager gehen auch in der union gibt
es sehr unterschiedliche positionen wir
haben auf der in zolder vielleicht
erstmal über die eu reden weil wir haben
ganz viele fragen hier von usern die
wissen möchten
warum immer deutschland warum kann man
nicht die anderen länder dazu bringen
sich auch zu also zu engagieren etwas zu
tun also ich habe hier mal dass das
unser gemeinsames dokument wo wir die
kommentare mal so sammeln meiner
kollegen im hintergrund und dann zum
beispiel hier in der werbung kommt immer
verwöhnt von der aufnahme von
flüchtlingen geredet wird immer direkt
deutschland warum werden die anderen
länder gar nicht erst gefragt möchte
wissen rostock auf youtube kann man das
schnellen kurz beantworten auch gefragt
und sie nehmen auch natürlich
flüchtlinge auf also ich war lange
korrespondent auch für spanien zuständig
und die dortige regierung hat dann eine
zeitlang sehr viele flüchtlinge aus
nordafrika aufgenommen bis dann
irgendwann auch dort die
kapazitätsgrenzen erreicht waren es ist
ja auch immer eine abwägung wie viel
kann ein land politisch verkraften es
hat donald tusk ja eben auch nochmal
erwähnt er sagte im grunde ist das immer
verbunden mit dem risiko dass
populistische oder rechtsextremen rechte
parteien das dann ausnutzen
mit migrations feindlicher politik also
insofern ist das eine delikate balance
die in
den einzelnen ländern gehalten werden
muss deutschland ist da belastbarer als
andere wir sind natürlich auch
wirtschaftlich stabiler als viele andere
aber beispielsweise in polen oder in
ungarn ist die ist es eine ganz klare
anti migrations position der regierung
und dagegen kann sich brüssel kann sich
die eu nicht durchsetzen
also für alle die gerade zugeschaltet
haben noch mal eine kurze
zusammenfassung wir haben gerade gehört
eine la merkel die bundeskanzlerin auf
einer veranstaltung der
konrad-adenauer-stiftung in berlin hat
sich geäußert
zu der großen frage was ist mit den
ganzen menschen im flüchtlingslager oder
des flüchtlingslagers moria das jahr
gebrannt hat vor zwei tagen auf der
griechischen insel lesbos passieren soll
deutschland und frankreich werden auf
bitten der griechischen regierung 400
unbegleitete minderjährige flüchtlinge
aufnehmen das hat sie jetzt bestätigt
die berichte kamen bei auch schon vorher
für anderthalb stunden und sie hat ganz
klar gerügt dass die europäische
flüchtlingspolitik im grunde nicht
existent ist unsere hauptstadt
korrespondent theo koll ist bei uns und
versucht ihre und eure fragen zu
beantworten das sind sehr viele ich muss
aber noch mal wirklich bitten dass ihr
versucht sachlich zu bleiben in den
kommentaren weil dann geht es doch sehr
drunter und drüber und ich kann wie
immer feststellen
es geht in zwei richtungen die einen
sagen keine aufnahme von brandstiftern
und die anderen sagen es muss immer erst
brennen und was passieren damit reagiert
wird und die menschen müssen da jetzt
endlich raus gibt es da überhaupt
wirklich einen konsens dem man finden
kann auch jetzt wenn wir auf die
deutsche politik gucken wo das sicher im
endeffekt in ähnliche lager spaltet gut
die ansagen hertha mit und die anderen
sagen auf gar keinen fall
ja in der tat das ist ein problem das
wir heute wieder gesehen haben in die
hessische europaministerin
beispielsweise hat im grunde genau diese
position die auch übrigens griechenland
hat bestätigt hat gesagt also wir dürfen
jetzt nicht im grunde das brandschatzen
des eigenen lagers damit belohnen dass
wir dann sagen okay also jetzt könnt ihr
in die in die europäischen länder
verteilt werden das sagt auch
griechenland weil sie fürchten dass
demnächst auch nachfolge
brandschatzungen anderen
lagern dann passieren sind da so relativ
strikt und auch der anderen satzung ist
das falsche wort aber nicht kuriert in
japan stiftungen meint es daran stifter
ruhpolding ja und und auf der anderen
seite natürlich diejenigen stimmen die
sagen wir können diese menschen da nicht
alleine lassen die schlafen im freien
haben jetzt überhaupt nichts mehr und
wir müssen sofort helfen die kanzlerin
hat ja eben auch gesagt dass sie ihre
verabredung mit der regierung in
griechenland ist eine zweiteilige also
erstmal sehr schnelle hilfe auch vor ort
also dass man da sofort sei es mit thw
unterkünfte und so weiter bauern hilft
und das zweite eben eine begrenzte
aufnahme von einer bestimmten anzahl von
flüchtlingen
es gibt ja doch direkte
lösungsvorschläge ich erinnere mich an
den innenminister von nrw der vor kurzem
interview was vorgeschlagen hat und
gesagt hat wir könnten ja so ne
kontingente machen wir nehmen 2000
andere neben 3000 5000 schicken wieder
nach hause gab es auf solche ganz
konkreten vorschläge irgendwelche
reaktionen jetzt heute also bisher hat
sich dazu die regierung noch nicht
geäußert denn man das hat die kanzlerin
ja gerade auch noch mal gesagt man
versucht natürlich wirklich eine
europäische lösung zu erzielen es gibt
am 30
september dazu ein treffen und die
europäische kommission will vorschläge
vorlegen also wenn man bleibt im grunde
in dieser in dieser schwierigen abwägung
einerseits jetzt die größte not zu
lindern und andererseits es nicht zu
einem zweiten 2015 werden zu lassen dass
im grunde deutschland das jenige land
ist dass die groß den großteil der
flüchtlinge aufnimmt
mit den entsprechenden politischen
folgen die das hätte so schaut nochmal
in die kommentare da gibt es ich sage
mal jetzt wenig konstruktives
tatsächlich von daher würde ich jetzt
mal sagen vielen dank für deine zeit
theo nach berlin vielen dank für eure
zeit und fürs zuschauen ich danke allen
die in den kommentaren sachlich
geblieben sind und würde sagen das thema
wird uns ja wohl die nächsten monate und
vielleicht auch weiterhin begleiten wir
bleiben dran aber für heute sagen wir
erstmal vielen dank fürs dabeisein und
tschüss